[Musica]
non so quanti di voi oggi qui si possono
aspettare una raccomandazione come
quella che vi sto per fare se c'è
qualcuno in sala
oppure nei parchi o nelle zone che non
sanno nuotare non si preoccupi resti
tranquillamente seduti sulla propria
poltrona e non accadrà nulla in realtà
prima di spiegarvi il perché di questa
raccomandazione
permettetemi faccio un passo indietro e
siamo a bologna città bellissima lo
avete capito la adoro bologna è circa la
stessa distanza tra la spezia e brescia
la spezia e brescia sono le mie due
città la prima in liguria dove ho
passato i primi 20 anni
la seconda gli altri 20 nella prima
città
ho imparato ad apprezzare il mare ad
amarlo e in un certo senso non poterne
fare a meno
pensate che quando ero piccolo e la
fantasia non è mai mancata
faceva un gioco forse un po
inimmaginabile che era quello di pensare
ai luoghi dove mi trovavo o dove mi
sarei trovato riempiti d'acqua e avrei
pensato come sarebbe stato pensavo come
sarebbe stato notarci all'interno non po
come se vuoi andaste a roma trovaste il
colosseo riempito d'acqua come enorme
piscina e ci potesse mutare all'interno
in un certo senso entusiasmante poi sono
cominciate a diventare un pochino più
grande per casa sono cominciati a
circolare i primi computer e se i miei
fratelli li usavano per giocare io in
realtà riversato tutta la mia fantasia
su quei piccoli tastini della tastiera
per inventare giochi mondi scenari cosa
che non esisteva
poi sono diventato grande ancora un po
di più e mi sono spostato
in lombardia dove ho trasformato la mia
passione della programmazione in un
lavoro e questo mi ha consentito di
sentirmi un privilegiato
tutti i giorni mi sento un privilegiato
in realtà mi sono sentito un
privilegiato anche quando gli
organizzatori del tè dix di bologna mi
hanno detto vieni ea raccontiamo
qualcosa e la cosa interessante anche un
po strana è che quando mi hanno detto di
venire qui
non so per quale strano motivo io ho
ripensato al primo gioco che facevo
quando ero piccolo e quindi se come ho
visto questa favolosa questo favoloso
posto dove saremmo stati veloci
immaginato pieno di pesci non ha solo
immaginato pieno di pesci ho pensato
come sarebbe stato nuotarci all'interno
e la cosa interessante è che da questo
momento
voi non ve ne rendete conto perché siete
ancora asciutti pro da questo momento
sto nuotando
all'interno di questo teatro e tra poco
noterete con me con una tecnologia
strana se volete che è simile a quella
che ho messo in testa che abbiamo
piazzato di fronte a me e che in grado
di vedere la stessa realtà che vedo io è
in grado in tutti i sensi
in questo scenario poi la parola è
ancora più valida è in grado di
immergervi nella stessa realtà in cui mi
trovo perché in questo momento io sto
notando e forse adesso riuscite a
vederlo anche a voi
quelli che vedete non sono dei cartoni
animati sono delle tartarughe dei pesci
che io ho qua intorno non vi faranno
niente
la cosa interessante che lo strumento
che io sulla testa e in grado di
comprendere in tempo rai e l'ambiente
e quindi ha compreso che c'è un
pavimento che ci sono delle persone che
ci sono delle pareti seppur distante c'è
un soffitto
ci sono degli oggetti e quindi decide in
maniera automatica di far muovere questi
ologrammi di vita propria all'interno di
questo scenario
credo che voi possiate vedere le
tartarughe ai pesci che mi stanno
ruotando intorno ad esso farò dei
movimenti forse estranei non ho bevuto
però vi porto da un'altra parte
adesso voi state vedendo con un'ottica
da spettatore quello che io sto vivendo
grazie a quella telecamera
vi porto dentro gli occhiali con me
dentro gli olo lance come si chiama
questo oggetto questo device qua in
testa perché ho deciso di portarmi un
regalo mi giro un po verso il palco e
con questi movimenti che adesso
probabilmente comincerete a vedere sullo
schermo perfetto io ho deciso di
portarvi un regalo che gli amici toscani
mi hanno mandato
volevo un po stupirvi e loro ho chiesto
che ci mandassero una cosina cui loro
sono abbastanza legati in realtà ci
siamo legati anche noi perché questa
cosa che vi porto sul palco sperando che
il palco rega il peso è una statua che è
universalmente riconosciuta come diciamo
il senso della bellezza umana
quello che io metto sul palco è il david
di michelangelo che pensate ha scolpito
in tre anni tra 1501 e 1504 firenze in
500 17 centimetri di marmo bianco
premente qualcuno di voi potrebbe dire
beh non è proprio il david di
michelangelo
no in questo momento perché da firenze
ce l'hanno mandato protetto da blocchi
di gesso
io mi tolgo
ecco di muovere lentamente la linea
testa in questo momento per farvi vedere
e apprezzare in ogni singolo dettaglio
la statua nella sua bellezza tanto c'è
una cosa interessante se notate il collo
del david noterete una piccola cicatrice
che a firenze è difficile da guardare
perché la statua non è così la statua è
così mike biggar ecco adesso la statua è
alta
517 centimetri di fronte a me con una
precisione fotografica in cui voi potete
vedere ogni singola venatura del marmo
ecco quello che vi porto sono due esempi
se volete è quella che sono degli
ologrammi che noi chiamiamo mix di
reality e vi faccio un passo indietro
un altro il passo indietro e questo
probabilmente voi avete già sentito
parlare di realtà virtuale
probabilmente avete sentito parlare
anche di realtà aumentata
questa è una cosa nuova la realtà
virtuale voi l'avete nel momento in cui
indossate un casco o un qualcosa che è
completamente vi occlude la vista dal
posto in cui siete e magicamente vi
ritrovate in cima all himalaya sulla
spiaggia di maui camminando sull'etna e
così via
però perdete completamente il senso
dell'ambiente in cui siete scenario
interessante se pensate ai piloti di
linea i simulatori che fanno quelle è
uno scenario di realtà virtuale seduti
in una cabina loro si immergono in una
realtà che completamente li trasporta
all'interno di una tratta aerea quello
che devono fare
la realtà aumentata è una cosa molto più
semplice voi potete prendere un
cellulare probabilmente già qualcuno di
voi lo fa o la utilizza andare magari
nella piazza qua fuori visualizzare la
piazza è un meccanismo una
vi dice che più avanti in fondo 100
metri c'è un ottimo ristorante oppure un
giochino che probabilmente qualcuno dei
vostri figli utilizza gli potrebbe far
trovare in mezzo alla piazza un
animaletto che il vostro figlio può
catturare però qual è la differenza che
se passasse una scavatore e facesse un
buco di 5 metri nella piazza
l'animaletto non potrebbe saperlo e
quindi sarebbe lì a mezz'aria la mixed
reality invece introduce un ragionamento
totalmente nuovo perché il mix tra la
realtà fisica e la realtà virtuale è un
mix che comprende l'ambiente fisico con
cui vi trovate comprende che c'è un
oggetto e interagisce con questi con
degli ologrammi se io avessi una pallina
digitale e la buttassi verso la t questa
rimbalzerebbe sulla t e poi sul
palcoscenico
se togli essi lati e facesse la stessa
operazione la palin andrebbe
direttamente per terra
questa è la grande differenza in quali
campi si può utilizzare una cosa del
genere
la slide dice tante cose che non mi
interessano perché mi interessa a darvi
un concetto solo oggi il limite che voi
avete è uno solo e la fantasia qualsiasi
industria settore ideali possa venire in
mente oggi la tecnologia in grado di
supportarli oggi l'unico limite che ci è
rimasta la fantasia perché con la
tecnologia riusciamo a fare qualsiasi
cosa vi possa venire in mente e se
volete ho giocato col portare delle
tartarughe su un palco a bologna
converrete con me inimmaginabile in
realtà li porto quattro esempi concreti
di come oggi olo lance viene utilizzato
il mondo il primo è qui sono anche più
affezionato riguarda la stazione
spaziale orbitante
l'uomo nella foto si chiama scott kelly
è stato il capitano della 46esima
missione spaziale fino a marzo del 2016
e la persona che ha ricevuto da terra
2 o lo lance che oggi sono sulla
stazione spaziale orbitante
questi dispositivi consentono gli
astronauti dissimulare provare e testare
formarsi su quelle che sono le attività
che poi dovranno fare fuori
immaginate che io il mio collega domani
abbiamo da fare una manutenzione sul
telescopio spaziale hubble ci mettiamo
il nostro dispositivo
l'ologramma che sarà tra di noi e
condiviso quindi io lui vedremo la
stessa cosa ci permetterà di simulare e
di provare quelle che sono le attività
che poi andremo a fare fuori una nota
società britannica che tra le altre cose
fa motori di aereo fino a qualche tempo
fa aveva due strade per fare formazione
la prima era quella di impacchettare un
motore a reazione spedirlo negli stati
uniti 50 ingegneri intorno al motore
facevano la loro formazione seconda
strada impacchettare gli ingegneri
portarli a londra
intorno al motore e fare loro formazione
oggi c'è una terza strada
il motore resta dov'è l'ingegnere
restano distribuiti sul territorio
americano ovunque essi siano e ognuno
col proprio lance è in grado
condividendo lo stesso lo gramma di fare
la stessa identica operazione che
facevano prima
converrete con me con un risparmio di
costi e di tempi pensate solo al
trasferimento assolutamente imbarazzante
il terzo senaro riguarda il giappone un
ospedale a tokyo ha fatto una
sperimentazione sta facendo una
sperimentazione con questi dispositivi
che consentono al medico chirurgo di non
distogliere mai l'attenzione da chi
necessita la propria attenzione il
paziente il medico non muove più la
testa da chi ha sul lettino e tutte le
informazioni di cui può aver bisogno le
può ottenere sul visore e se volesse
fare una conference call
visto che anche prima parliamo di skype
con un collega che magari a new york ed
è molto bravo su quella patologia grazie
alla telecamera frontale ad alta
definizione può aprire una
e a new york il dottore vedrà ciò che
fisicamente è presente sul lettino
anche questo apre degli scenari
sicuramente favolosi
non so se qualcuno di voi sta per
cambiare macchina però potrebbe prendere
un aereo andare in svezia perché partito
di una certa marca entra in uno showroom
e non trovare auto lo showroom è vuoto
certo lì per lì magari uno dice forse ho
sbagliato posto in realtà il marchio
dell'out sulle varie pareti magari vi fa
pensare che siete nel posto giusto
un commerciale o chi per esso verrà da
voi ad accogliervi in svezia non vi
offrono il caffè però magari vi offro
nuovo lance una volta che voi lo mettete
potete interagire direttamente con
dispositivo e chiedere un certo modello
di auto e vederlo in forma 1 a 1 davanti
a voi magari blu non ero noc l'assetto
sportivo testa dentro gli interni in
pelle chiara ma in pelle scura aspetta
che forse mi piace chiama mia moglie
ovunque essa sia
mia moglie per sicuramente tutti non
avrete messo a casa mia moglie si mette
lolo lance vedrà nella sua sala nella
nostra sala la stessa macchina
questo è un altro aggiornamento
immaginate di questo stesso questo
stesso scenario in un centro commerciale
dove oggi voi magari andate e potete
vedere l'ultimo modello di un'auto
provvedete quel modello di quel colore
di quella configurazione che è stato
portato lì
immaginate la bellezza invece di provare
un dispositivo e chiedere un certo
modello di auto non un altro no di un
colore no con un altro assetto e così
via
questi sono alcuni esempi
se volete della della tecnologia però
c'è una cosa che per me è importante e
ve la voglio passare ve la voglio
sottolineare perché si sente spessissimo
no questa parola artificial intelligence
l'intelligenza artificiale ormai ne
sentiamo parlare da ogni poro ovunque in
ogni angolo
l'intelligenza artificiale per noi è
questa non è una cosa che ci mangerà
ma è una tecnologia o delle tecnologie
che possono permetterci di aumentare la
conoscenza la competenza di arricchirci
e permetterci di fare cose in più e cose
nuove e non vi nascondo che un sogno un
desiderio quando sono entrato qua quando
iniziato a parlare guardandovi ho
immaginato che qualcuno di voi pensasse
come inimmaginabile
alcuni di questi scenari il mio
desiderio è che oggi esca da questo
teatro
sapendo e avendo ben chiaro che di
l'immaginabile non c'è più niente
grazie
[Applauso]